bienvenido de nuevo a Comprendiendo la Información y Computación Cuántica, mi nombre es John Wattrus y soy el director técnico
de educación en IBM Quantum. Esta es la lección 11 de la serie y es la tercera lección de la
tercera unidad, que trata sobre la formulación general de la información cuántica. Esta lección es sobre las mediciones, que representan una
interfaz entre la información cuántica y la clásica. Cuando se realiza una medición sobre un sistema mientras está en un
estado cuántico, se extrae información clásica que revela algo sobre ese estado cuántico y generalmente cambia o
destruye ese estado en el proceso. En una formulación simplificada de la información cuántica que fue discutida
en la primera unidad de la serie, normalmente restringimos nuestra atención a las mediciones proyectivas, incluyendo el
tipo más simple de medición: las mediciones en la base estándar. Sin embargo, es posible generalizar la noción de medición
y resulta ser algo bastante útil. En esta lección hablaremos sobre las mediciones en toda su generalidad,
incluyendo cómo se describen en términos matemáticos y cómo encajan en la formulación general de la
información cuántica. Hacia el final de la lección también echaremos un vistazo a un par de nociones fundamentales relacionadas con las mediciones, a saber: la discriminación de estados cuánticos
y la tomografía de estados cuánticos. Así que empecemos. Aquí tienes un resumen de la
lección. Como solemos hacer, comenzaremos con los fundamentos, incluyendo un par de formas diferentes pero equivalentes de
describir las mediciones en términos matemáticos. En particular, podemos describir las mediciones mediante colecciones de matrices
y también podemos describirlas como canales, como mencioné en la lección anterior. También discutiremos las mediciones parciales
o, en otras palabras, mediciones que se realizan sobre solo una parte de un sistema compuesto más grande.
Luego pasaremos al teorema de Neymark, que es un hecho fundamental sobre las mediciones que básicamente
dice que las mediciones generales siempre pueden implementarse de una manera sencilla que recuerda a las representaciones de Stein spring
de los canales. En resumen, las mediciones generales siempre pueden implementarse introduciendo primero un
sistema de espacio de trabajo inicializado, luego realizando una operación unitaria y finalmente realizando una medición en la base estándar
sobre el sistema de espacio de trabajo. Esto resulta ser bastante fácil de demostrar y veremos cómo funciona, y también
veremos cómo esto se conecta con las llamadas mediciones no destructivas, que describiré. Por último, en la última parte de la
lección discutiremos la discriminación de estados cuánticos y la tomografía de estados cuánticos. Comenzaremos con las descripciones matemáticas
de las mediciones. Las mediciones nos proporcionan una interfaz entre la información cuántica y la
clásica. Cuando se realiza una medición sobre un sistema mientras está en algún estado cuántico, se extrae información clásica
sobre ese estado cuántico. Además, el estado cuántico generalmente cambia o posiblemente
es destruido por completo. Inicialmente, centraremos nuestra atención en las llamadas mediciones destructivas, donde
un estado cuántico entra y solo sale información clásica, por lo que no hay especificación del
estado cuántico posterior a la medición del sistema que fue medido. Intuitivamente, podemos imaginar que una medición destructiva
destruye el sistema que fue medido, por lo que su estado después de que la medición tiene lugar no está
especificado. Esto no significa literalmente que los dispositivos físicos sean necesariamente destruidos, es simplemente una descripción matemática
y es muy útil porque ayuda a mantener las cosas simples y a centrarse en los aspectos
matemáticos esenciales de las mediciones. Existen en particular dos formas equivalentes de describir las mediciones destructivas
que mencioné durante el resumen de la lección. Una forma de describir una medición destructiva
es mediante una colección de matrices, donde en particular tenemos una matriz para cada posible resultado de la medición.
Una segunda forma de describir una medición destructiva es mediante un canal, donde la
entrada es el estado del sistema que está siendo medido y la salida es siempre una matriz de densidad diagonal, que podemos
interpretar como una descripción de una distribución de probabilidad sobre los posibles resultados clásicos de la medición.
Las dos descripciones son equivalentes, y eso es bastante útil porque nos permite elegir la descripción que sea más conveniente en una
situación dada. También hablaremos sobre las mediciones no destructivas, donde además de un resultado clásico de la medición,
el estado cuántico posterior a la medición del sistema que fue medido también está
especificado. Las mediciones no destructivas son importantes y surgen con frecuencia, pero hay un sentido en el que
no son tan fundamentales como las mediciones destructivas en términos matemáticos. En particular, como resulta,
las mediciones no destructivas siempre pueden describirse como composiciones de canales y mediciones destructivas, y con
eso veremos cómo funciona un poco más adelante en la lección. Ahora veamos cómo las mediciones, es decir, las mediciones destructivas,
pueden describirse como colecciones de matrices. A lo largo de esta discusión supondremos que X es un sistema que está
siendo medido y, por simplicidad, haremos un par de suposiciones. Primero, supondremos que el
conjunto de estados clásicos de X consiste en los enteros del 0 al n menos uno para algún entero positivo n, y los posibles
resultados de la medición son los enteros del 0 al M menos uno, también para algún entero positivo M. No es necesario
que haya ninguna relación entre los números n y M; ambos son enteros positivos arbitrarios y, por supuesto, podríamos reemplazar
estos conjuntos por conjuntos de estados clásicos arbitrarios si quisiéramos. Primero recordemos cómo funcionan las mediciones proyectivas,
de las que hablamos por primera vez en la tercera lección de la serie. Dado que suponemos que
los resultados de la medición son los enteros del 0 al n menos uno, describimos una medición proyectiva mediante una colección
de proyecciones Pi 0 a Pi M menos uno que suman la matriz identidad, y estas matrices tienen todas filas y
columnas correspondientes a los estados clásicos de X, o en otras palabras, todas son matrices de n por n.
Si x está en un estado cuántico descrito por un vector de estado cuántico s, entonces cada posible resultado de medición
a aparece con una probabilidad igual a la norma euclídea al cuadrado de Pi a multiplicada
por el vector s. La norma euclídea al cuadrado de cualquier vector es igual al producto interno de ese
vector consigo mismo, así que obtenemos la expresión que se muestra en la pantalla y podemos simplificarla un poco
usando el hecho de que Pi a es una proyección, de modo que multiplicarla por sí misma no cambia nada.
Y finalmente podemos reescribir la expresión obtenida de una manera ligeramente diferente usando la propiedad cíclica
de la traza, como se muestra en la pantalla. Y si no queda claro por qué queremos escribir la expresión así,
la respuesta breve es que queremos entender cómo funcionan las mediciones proyectivas para las matrices de densidad
matrices y en particular por linealidad tenemos que si el estado de X está descrito por una matriz de densidad rho en lugar
de un vector de estado cuántico, entonces la probabilidad de que aparezca el resultado a viene dada por la traza de la proyección
Pi a multiplicada por la matriz de densidad rho, lo cual tiene que ser así porque, como hemos visto,
siempre podemos pensar en una matriz de densidad como un promedio ponderado de estados puros, y si promediamos las
probabilidades correspondientes obtenemos esta expresión porque la traza es una función lineal, así que esa es la expresión que
buscamos, y podemos simplificar un poco las cosas para centrarnos en las matrices de
densidad. El objetivo principal de hacer esto, por cierto, es establecer un punto de referencia con lo que ya hemos aprendido
y ver que esta descripción de las mediciones proyectivas es en realidad un caso especial de una descripción más general de mediciones que estamos
a punto de ver. Así que lo que haré ahora es reemplazar esta descripción de cómo funcionan las mediciones proyectivas para matrices de densidad
por la descripción para mediciones generales, para que podamos entender la relación. Y aquí está:
una medición general, no necesariamente proyectiva, se describe mediante una colección de matrices semidefinidas positivas
p 0 hasta PM menos uno que suman la identidad, y si esta medición se realiza sobre X cuando está
en un estado descrito por una matriz de densidad rho, entonces cada resultado a aparece con probabilidad igual a la traza de PA multiplicada por
rho. En resumen, lo único que ha cambiado es que hemos relajado la condición sobre estas matrices; en particular, las matrices
no necesitan ser matrices de proyección, solo necesitan ser semidefinidas positivas, y correspondientemente he reemplazado la letra Pi por la letra P,
porque Pi es el nombre convencional para una proyección, mientras que yo prefiero usar la letra P para las matrices
semidefinidas positivas. Esto es una generalización de la descripción que teníamos para las mediciones proyectivas, por cierto, porque las matrices de proyección son siempre semidefinidas
positivas y, de hecho, pueden definirse alternativamente como matrices semidefinidas positivas cuyos valores propios
solo pueden ser cero o uno. Podemos observar que esta definición
tiene sentido en que siempre obtenemos un vector de probabilidad para las probabilidades de los resultados de la siguiente
manera: primero, estos números que denominé probabilidades de resultado son siempre números reales no negativos, lo cual se da
porque tanto PA como rho son semidefinidas positivas, y la traza del producto de dos matrices semidefinidas positivas
es siempre un número real no negativo, y eso lo dejo para que pienses por qué es así.
Y segundo, los números tienen que sumar uno porque la traza es lineal, las
matrices p 0 hasta PN menos 1 deben sumar la identidad, y las matrices de densidad tienen traza igual a
uno, por lo que independientemente de cuál sea la matriz de densidad rho de partida, las probabilidades de resultado siempre formarán un
vector de probabilidad. Ahora veamos algunos ejemplos. Ya mencioné que
las mediciones proyectivas son un caso especial de las mediciones generales porque las proyecciones son siempre semidefinidas positivas,
pero está bien empezar con algo sencillo, así que comencemos con una medición en la base estándar de un qubit. Podemos representar una medición en la base estándar
de un qubit mediante dos matrices P 0 y P1 definidas como se muestra en pantalla: P 0 es el ket cero bra cero, y P1 es el ket uno
bra uno. Ambas son matrices semidefinidas positivas y, de hecho, son proyecciones, y claramente suman la
identidad, por lo que juntas describen una medición. Si aplicamos esta medición a un qubit
en un estado descrito por una matriz de densidad rho, la probabilidad de que aparezca el resultado cero es la traza de P 0 por rho,
y la probabilidad del resultado uno es la traza de P1 por rho, y por la propiedad cíclica de la traza obtenemos
las dos entradas diagonales de rho, como era de esperar. Aquí hay otro ejemplo donde
las matrices no son proyecciones. Sí son semidefinidas positivas, y resulta que también son matrices de
densidad, pero eso no es lo importante. Lo que sí importa es que suman la identidad, por lo que juntas describen una
medición. Podemos ver qué sucede cuando esta medición se realiza sobre un qubit en el estado más, por ejemplo, solo para
ver cómo funciona con un ejemplo de estado, y el cálculo de las probabilidades se muestra en
pantalla. Observa en particular que aunque el estado más es un estado puro y podemos representar ese estado por el vector de estado cuántico ket más, sí tenemos que
introducir la representación en matriz de densidad de ese estado, que es ket más bra más, en las fórmulas para obtener
las probabilidades. Y déjame remarcar también que, como estamos hablando de una medición destructiva, no hay ninguna
especificación del estado cuántico postmedición de este qubit, así que lo único que tenemos es una especificación de las
probabilidades de los resultados. Aquí hay un último ejemplo por ahora, y es bastante interesante. Una vez más es una medición de un
único qubit, y para describirla comenzaremos definiendo cuatro vectores de estado cuántico conocidos como los estados
tetraédricos. La razón por la que se llaman estados tetraédricos es porque corresponden a los cuatro vértices de
un tetraedro regular inscrito en la esfera de Bloch. Y para ser precisos, cuando decimos que es un tetraedro regular
nos referimos a un sólido de cuatro caras donde cada una es un triángulo equilátero, así que hay una simetría perfecta: cada
arista tiene la misma longitud y se forma el mismo ángulo entre cualquier par de aristas
adyacentes. Ahora podemos definir una medición interesante con cuatro resultados posibles, como se muestra en pantalla. En otras palabras, podemos tomar nuestras
matrices como las representaciones en matriz de densidad de estos estados divididas por dos. Estas son definitivamente semidefinidas
positivas porque son matrices de densidad divididas por dos, y podrías hacer la aritmética para comprobar
que en efecto suman la identidad. Pero otra forma de verlo es pensar en la simetría: si promediamos estos cuatro estados
obtenemos el estado completamente mezclado, que está en el centro de la esfera de Bloch. Pero como estamos dividiendo
cada uno por dos en lugar de por cuatro, obtenemos el doble del estado completamente mezclado, que es la identidad. No diré nada más sobre
esta medición por ahora, salvo observar que no es una medición proyectiva, pero sí es un buen ejemplo y
la veremos aparecer de nuevo más adelante en la lección. Otra forma de describir las mediciones generales es como canales, como veremos
ahora. La idea aquí es que los estados probabilísticos clásicos pueden representarse mediante matrices de densidad diagonales, y por lo tanto,
como los resultados de las mediciones son clásicos, podemos pensar en las mediciones como canales donde la salida es siempre una matriz de densidad diagonal
que describe el resultado de la medición. Así que veamos esto con un poco más de detalle. Si pensamos
de manera abstracta en una medición general, podemos describir esa medición como un canal phi. El sistema de entrada del canal es
el sistema X que se está midiendo, y el sistema de salida es un sistema Y cuyos estados clásicos corresponden a los
resultados de la medición, que tomamos como los enteros de 0 a N menos uno para algún entero positivo
M. Y como los resultados de las mediciones son clásicos, requerimos que para toda matriz de densidad de entrada rho del sistema
X, la salida phi(rho) debe ser una matriz de densidad diagonal. Por ejemplo, si pensamos en una
la medición en la base estándar de un qubit y si pensamos en esa medición como un channel podemos expresarla como se ve aquí en la pantalla
si la matriz de densidad de entrada es rho, obtendremos el resultado cero con una probabilidad igual a bra 0 rho ket 0
y obtendremos el resultado uno con probabilidad bra 1 rho ket 1 y así, si expresamos estos resultados clásicos
de medición como matrices de densidad, obtenemos esta expresión para el channel correspondiente y resulta que
no es otro que el channel de desfasamiento completo, lo cual es coherente con la idea de que el channel de desfasamiento completo
representa una forma extrema de decoherencia, que puede significar cosas distintas, pero cuando uso ese término me refiero
a la tendencia de los estados cuánticos a volverse clásicos porque el entorno alrededor de cualquier sistema del que
estemos hablando está observando en cierto sentido, o dicho de otro modo, está midiendo
así que los resultados de medición pueden describirse como channels, como acabo de explicar, pero esto no es solo una posibilidad, es una
caracterización de las mediciones generales y lo que quiero decir con eso es lo siguiente: por supuesto que existen channels
que no representan mediciones porque la salida podría no ser siempre una matriz de densidad diagonal, pero si es el
caso de que la salida de un channel sea siempre una matriz de densidad diagonal sin importar qué estado de entrada rho elijamos, entonces necesariamente es posible
expresar ese channel en la forma que se muestra en pantalla para alguna elección de una medición, es decir, una colección de
matrices semidefinidas positivas que suman la identidad, y eso es bueno por múltiples razones, incluido el hecho de que
básicamente nos dice que nuestra definición de mediciones como colecciones de matrices no omite
nada; otra forma de decirlo es que esta manera de pensar en las mediciones como channels es operacional
o quizás axiomática, en el sentido de que captura lo que debería ser una medición: un proceso físico que
transforma información cuántica en información clásica, y resulta que es completamente equivalente a nuestra primera
descripción de las mediciones, que es puramente algebraica; no voy a demostrar la equivalencia en este video, pero
no es difícil y si te interesa puedes encontrar la demostración en el material escrito de la lección, cuyo enlace está en el video
hemos hablado de lo que ocurre cuando se realiza una medición general sobre un sistema en un estado dado
al menos para el caso de mediciones destructivas; a continuación hablaremos de mediciones parciales, es decir, cuando solo
una parte de un sistema compuesto es medida; para ser precisos, supongamos que tenemos un par de sistemas XZ que
juntos están en un estado descrito por una matriz de densidad rho, y se realiza sobre el sistema X una medición descrita por una colección de matrices semidefinidas positivas que suman la
identidad; naturalmente, esto produce un resultado de medición y, como estamos hablando de mediciones destructivas, podemos imaginar que el proceso de medición destruye el sistema
X, pero aún tenemos el sistema Z del que preocuparnos y necesitamos entender cómo la medición de X afecta el
estado de Z; primero hablemos de las probabilidades de los resultados
como estamos hablando de una medición del sistema X solo, las probabilidades de los distintos
resultados solo pueden depender del estado de X por separado, es decir, solo pueden depender del
estado reducido de X; en particular, la probabilidad de que aparezca un resultado dado a viene dada por
la misma fórmula de antes, que es la traza de PA por el estado reducido de X, que denotamos por rho
subX; el estado rho subX se obtiene de rho trazando Z, así que podemos hacer esa
sustitución y, aunque puede no ser inmediatamente obvio, la expresión que obtenemos puede escribirse alternativamente como se
muestra en pantalla: es la traza de PA tensoriado con la matriz identidad del sistema Z, multiplicado por
rho; esa es una igualdad que definitivamente vale la pena tomarse el tiempo de verificar; es intuitiva: no hacemos
nada en absoluto a Z, así que tiene sentido que la identidad en Z aparezca de esta forma, pero también puede verificarse
algebraicamente y te dejo eso a ti, junto con la sugerencia de considerar primero el caso en que rho es un producto tensorial de dos matrices y después
usar la linealidad para concluir que debe funcionar para todo rho; también diré que no depende del hecho de que PA
sea semidefinida positiva ni de que rho sea una matriz de densidad: es una igualdad que funciona para cualquier elección de
matrices en lugar de PA y rho, siempre y cuando tengan las dimensiones correctas para que la expresión tenga
sentido; y ahora veamos cómo el estado de Z se ve afectado por la medición; el enfoque natural desde
mi punto de vista es pensar en la medición como un channel; aquí está el channel que asociamos con nuestra medición y lo estamos
pensando como un channel del sistema X a un nuevo sistema Y cuyos estados clásicos corresponden a los resultados de la medición; así que en esta fórmula
sigma representa un estado del sistema X solo; si aplicamos este channel al
sistema X mientras el par XZ está en el estado rho, obtendremos la matriz de densidad que tenemos justo aquí; de nuevo,
tómate el tiempo que necesites para verificar esto y de nuevo mi sugerencia es considerar primero el caso en que rho es un tensor
producto de dos matrices y luego usar la linealidad; ahora bien, vimos este tipo de estado
donde el primer sistema es clásico y el segundo es cuántico como ejemplo en la lección de la matriz de densidad
cada a ocurre con cierta probabilidad, que es la traza del segundo factor tensorial, así que puedes pensar
en estos segundos factores tensoriales como matrices de densidad multiplicadas por probabilidades; así que para obtener el estado de
Z condicionado a obtener un resultado de medición particular a, simplemente dividimos por la probabilidad, o dicho de otro modo,
normalizamos el segundo factor tensorial dividiéndolo por su propia traza; así que en resumen, si realizamos una
medición en X mientras el par XZ está en el estado rho, esto es lo que ocurre: primero, cada resultado a aparece
con probabilidad igual a la traza de PA tensoriado con la identidad multiplicado por rho, y segundo, condicionado a obtener
un resultado de medición particular a, el estado de Z viene dado por la expresión mostrada en pantalla, que es lo que obtenemos
al normalizar la matriz que acabamos de ver hace un momento, y es lo mismo que dividir la matriz por la probabilidad
de que aparezca a; debo mencionar que esto solo tiene sentido si la probabilidad es distinta de cero, porque de lo contrario estamos
dividiendo entre cero, pero eso está bien porque no necesitamos preocuparnos por cosas que no ocurren; en esta parte de
la lección discutiremos un teorema simple pero fundamental sobre las mediciones, conocido como el teorema de Neymar
en pocas palabras, lo que dice es que cualquier medición puede implementarse como se sugiere en la figura de la pantalla
poniendo esto en palabras: una medición general dada sobre un sistema X puede implementarse de la siguiente manera
primero introducimos un sistema de espacio de trabajo inicializado Y cuyos estados clásicos son los posibles resultados de la medición, que asumimos están numerados
de 0 a n menos uno; luego se realiza una operación unitaria U sobre el par
YX y después se realiza una medición en la base estándar sobre Y, así que todo básicamente está establecido en
aquí, excepto por la elección de U, y lo que dice el teorema es que de hecho es posible elegir esta unitaria
operación U de forma que las probabilidades para los distintos resultados siempre coincidan con la medición general dada
ahora veamos cómo se demuestra el teorema de Neymar, y no es difícil: solo necesitamos hacer una buena elección para
la operación unitaria U y verificar que funciona, pero primero necesitamos un hecho básico
de la teoría de matrices: para cualquier matriz semidefinida positiva P, siempre existe una única semidefinida positiva
matriz Q tal que Q al cuadrado es igual a P. En general puede haber muchas matrices cuyo cuadrado nos dé P, pero
siempre hay exactamente una que es semidefinida positiva. La notación que usamos para denotar esa matriz es la raíz cuadrada de
P, y así también nos referimos a ella en palabras. Si quieres calcular la raíz cuadrada de P para alguna
matriz semidefinida positiva P, puedes hacerlo calculando primero una descomposición espectral de P y luego
reemplazando cada uno de los valores propios por su raíz cuadrada y dejando los vectores propios sin cambio. Los valores propios son todos no
negativos, así que esto tiene sentido, y es bastante fácil ver que la matriz que obtenemos es de hecho semidefinida positiva
y que su cuadrado es P. El hecho de que sea única es otra cuestión; no es difícil de
demostrar usando algunos hechos básicos sobre matrices, pero es algo tangencial a la lección y simplemente tomaremos esa parte
como dada. Ahora que tenemos ese concepto en mente, es bastante fácil especificar
una operación unitaria U que funcione. Cualquier matriz unitaria que coincida con el patrón que se muestra en pantalla funcionará de hecho
Las primeras n columnas, suponiendo que X tiene n estados clásicos como antes, se obtienen apilando las raíces cuadradas de
las matrices que describen la medición una sobre otra, y las columnas restantes pueden ser lo que
queramos; no importa, siempre que la matriz completa sea unitaria
y, por cierto, si estás notando una similitud con la conexión entre las representaciones de Krauss y Stinespring de canales, no es coincidencia, y
de hecho lo que tenemos aquí es esencialmente un caso especial de eso, donde nuestras matrices de Kraus resultan ser todas positivas
semidefinidas. Así que hay dos cosas que necesitamos verificar: la primera es que esta elección de U realmente funciona, y la
segunda es que es posible elegir las columnas no especificadas de forma que U sea unitaria. Empecemos con la primera
aquí está el estado con el que comenzamos: el sistema inferior Y se inicializa al estado cero, mientras que el sistema superior
comienza en el estado rho, y luego aplicamos U, lo que significa que conjugamos por
U. Podemos escribir todo esto en términos de matrices de bloques como se muestra en pantalla: tenemos U a la izquierda, U dagger a la
derecha, y cero bra cero tensorial con rho en el medio, que toma la forma que tenemos aquí, donde rho está en
la esquina superior izquierda y ceros en el resto. Y si piensas en este producto por un momento, es evidente que las
entradas no especificadas de U no importan para nada, porque siempre se multiplican por entradas cero de esta
matriz del medio. Y si trabajamos la multiplicación, obtenemos esta
matriz que se muestra aquí, descrita como una matriz de bloques, o alternativamente podemos expresarla usando notación de índices
así, que de hecho es la forma más conveniente para nosotros. Así que centrémonos en esta
expresión y, para mayor comodidad, démosle a esta matriz, que es una matriz de densidad, el nombre
Sigma. El último paso es la medición en la base estándar sobre Y, así que calculemos el estado reducido en Y, y
eso es fácil dada la expresión que tenemos: simplemente trazamos X, que corresponde al segundo factor
tensorial. Así que la probabilidad de que aparezca cualquier resultado dado a es la entrada diagonal correspondiente a a. Podemos escribir
eso así, y es igual a la traza de la raíz cuadrada de PA por rho por la raíz
cuadrada de PA, y por la propiedad cíclica de la traza obtenemos la traza de PA por rho
que es lo que esperábamos. Así que las probabilidades de que aparezcan los distintos resultados son correctas: siempre coinciden
con la medición original con la que empezamos. La segunda cosa que necesitamos verificar
es que es posible completar las columnas no especificadas de U de forma que se vuelva
unitaria. Esto se sigue del hecho de que las primeras n columnas, que son las formadas por las raíces cuadradas de las matrices que describen la
medición, son ortonormales, y eso se puede verificar de forma bastante directa. Los detalles relevantes están aquí
en pantalla, así que pausa el video y tómate unos momentos para pensar en eso si quieres, pero como sugerí antes,
en realidad es un caso especial de algo que encontramos en la lección anterior, y esa es la
demostración. Hasta ahora en la lección nos hemos centrado en mediciones destructivas, es decir, aquellas donde no hay especificación del
estado cuántico post-medición del sistema que fue medido. Para una medición no destructiva, en cambio, hay
no solo un resultado de medición clásico, sino también un estado cuántico post-medición del sistema que fue medido, y como
veremos, hay una conexión natural con el teorema de Neymar. De hecho hay distintas formas de formular las mediciones no destructivas
en términos matemáticos, pero empezaremos con una formulación que surge básicamente de manera directa del teorema de Neymar
Considera una medición general, es decir, una destructiva, descrita por una colección de matrices semidefinidas positivas
p 0 hasta PN menos uno que suman la identidad. Podemos entonces convertir esta
medición en una medición no destructiva simplemente considerando la implementación de esta medición que discutimos en el contexto del teorema de Neymar
introducimos un nuevo sistema Y, lo hacemos interactuar con X a través de una operación unitaria U y luego realizamos una
medición en la base estándar sobre Y. Así el sistema X sigue ahí y podemos considerar su
estado, y basándonos en el análisis que hicimos podemos determinar que el estado post-medición de X condicionado
a obtener un resultado de medición particular a viene dado por una matriz de densidad que se ve
así: en palabras, conjugamos por la raíz cuadrada de la matriz de medición correspondiente y luego
normalizamos. Otra forma de formular las mediciones no destructivas, que es más general, es en términos de matrices de Kraus
de canales, y esta es la definición de mediciones que encontrarás en el conocido libro de texto de Nielsen y
Chuang, por ejemplo. Supongamos que m0 hasta m m menos 1 son matrices cuadradas que satisfacen
la ecuación que se muestra en pantalla, es decir, que podríamos pensar en estas matrices como matrices de Kraus que describen un
canal. De hecho estas matrices sí describen un canal, pero también describen una medición no destructiva
y la forma en que funciona cuando se mide un sistema en un estado dado rho es: primero, las probabilidades de los resultados son
las dadas por la ecuación que se muestra en pantalla: cada resultado aparece con probabilidad igual a la traza de ma por
rho por ma dagger, y condicionado a que aparezca el resultado a, el estado del sistema medido
el sistema se ve así; las mediciones no destructivas de este tipo se pueden implementar de una
manera similar a lo que vimos para el teorema de Naymark, y te dejo eso para que pienses si
quieres; es posible generalizar el concepto de medición no destructiva aún más, por ejemplo,
existe el concepto de un llamado instrumento cuántico que a veces es muy útil, pero no lo voy a cubrir en este
video. En la última parte de la lección voy a hablar brevemente sobre dos tareas relacionadas con las mediciones: la discriminación de estados cuánticos y la tomografía de estados cuánticos.
Hay mucho que decir sobre ambos conceptos y realmente solo vamos a rascar la
superficie. Empecemos por aclarar a qué se refieren estos términos y en qué se diferencian.
Primero está la discriminación de estados cuánticos. La idea es que tenemos una colección conocida de estados cuánticos
de algún sistema junto con probabilidades asociadas a estos estados. Para ser precisos, supongamos
que rho 0 hasta rho M menos 1 son matrices de densidad que representan posibles estados cuánticos de un sistema X, y p 0
hasta p N menos uno son probabilidades asociadas a estos estados. Si reunimos las probabilidades en un solo
vector, obtenemos un vector de probabilidad. Una forma concisa de decir esto, por cierto, es que tenemos un ensemble de estados cuánticos
y ahora, de manera abstracta, podemos pensar en la discriminación de estados cuánticos como una tarea o como un problema:
primero se elige aleatoriamente un número entre 0 y N menos uno según las probabilidades; el sistema X se prepara entonces
en el estado correspondiente al número seleccionado aleatoriamente, y el objetivo es determinar mediante
una medición de X cuál fue el número elegido. Entonces tenemos un número finito de
alternativas junto con una distribución a priori, y el objetivo es determinar cuál alternativa ocurrió realmente. Para algunas elecciones de estados y
probabilidades esto puede ser fácil, y para otras puede no ser posible hacerlo sin alguna probabilidad de cometer un error.
Hay varias preguntas específicas que podríamos hacernos, como cuál es la probabilidad mínima de cometer un error
y cómo es una medición que alcanza esta probabilidad mínima de error. La tomografía de estados cuánticos, por otro lado,
es diferente. Aquí tenemos un estado cuántico desconocido de un sistema, así que generalmente
no hay información a priori ni información sobre posibles alternativas. Esta vez, sin embargo, no es una sola copia del estado lo que está disponible,
sino que se ponen a disposición muchas copias independientes, es decir, para algún número posiblemente grande
n, tenemos n sistemas idénticos X1 hasta Xn que están cada uno preparado independientemente en el estado
rho, y esta vez el objetivo es encontrar una aproximación de este estado cuántico desconocido como una matriz de densidad, midiendo
los sistemas. En resumen, en la discriminación de estados cuánticos tenemos una sola copia del
estado y estamos intentando discriminar entre un número finito de alternativas conocidas, y en la tomografía de estados cuánticos tenemos muchas copias independientes
de un estado cuántico desconocido, y el objetivo es encontrar una descripción de ese estado o al menos una buena aproximación del
mismo. La discriminación de estados cuánticos es interesante porque abstrae un tipo de situación que surge comúnmente en
la computación y la criptografía, por ejemplo, donde una alternativa de un conjunto finito de posibilidades ha ocurrido y nosotros o alguien más está intentando
descubrir cuál fue midiendo un sistema cuántico. El caso no trivial más simple es
cuando hay solo dos alternativas, es decir, que m es igual a dos, por lo que la tarea es discriminar entre un par
de estados. Este caso resulta ser esencialmente un problema completamente resuelto, asumiendo que el objetivo es minimizar
la probabilidad de una discriminación incorrecta. Hay una elección óptima para una medición y a menudo se llama
la medición de Helstrom. Es una medición proyectiva de hecho, y se puede describir de la siguiente
manera: primero consideramos la diferencia ponderada entre las dos alternativas, es decir, p 0 por rho 0 menos p1 por rho 1.
Multiplicamos la probabilidad de extraer cada uno de estos dos estados por los estados mismos, y tomamos la
diferencia. Esa es una matriz hermítica porque es igual a su propia transpuesta conjugada, por lo que tiene una descomposición espectral
y sabemos en particular que los valores propios son todos números reales. Supongamos entonces que tenemos una
descomposición espectral escrita en la forma que se muestra en pantalla. Lo que hacemos a continuación es recopilar los
valores propios en dos conjuntos, donde todos los valores propios positivos están en un conjunto y todos los valores propios negativos están en
el otro. Para ser precisos, tomemos S0 como el conjunto de todos los índices k para los cuales el correspondiente valor propio Lambda K es
no negativo, y sea S1 el conjunto de los índices restantes, que son los que corresponden a valores propios negativos.
En realidad no importa qué conjunto contiene los índices que corresponden a valores propios cero. Aquí estamos haciendo
una elección arbitraria de incluir el menos cero, pero no haría ninguna diferencia si algunos o todos ellos se incluyeran en S1. Lo que realmente importa es
separar los valores propios positivos y negativos. Finalmente, definimos dos proyecciones Pi
0 y Pi 1 como se muestra en pantalla. En palabras, Pi 0 es la proyección sobre el
subespacio generado por los vectores propios correspondientes a valores propios no negativos, y Pi 1 es la proyección sobre el subespacio
generado por los vectores propios correspondientes a valores propios negativos. Estas son de hecho proyecciones y
si las sumamos obtenemos la matriz identidad, porque los vectores propios S 0 hasta S N menos uno forman una
base ortonormal. Si esta medición se realiza en la situación en cuestión, es decir, que
el estado que se mide es rho 0 con probabilidad p 0 y rho 1 con probabilidad p1, resulta que
la probabilidad de una identificación correcta tiene una fórmula bastante simple en términos de los valores propios Lambda 0 hasta Lambda n menos
uno. No voy a detallar el cálculo en este video; puedes consultar el contenido escrito enlazado en la descripción del video si
te interesa, o ver si puedes convencerte de que esta fórmula es correcta. También podemos expresar esta
probabilidad usando una norma matricial comúnmente llamada la norma traza. Es una notación similar a la norma euclidiana para vectores,
excepto que tenemos un subíndice de uno para indicar que es la norma traza. La norma traza es muy importante y es
muy común en la computación cuántica, pero no voy a decir mucho más sobre ella en esta lección. Una forma de
definirla para matrices hermíticas es que es la suma de los valores absolutos de los valores propios, así que puedes pensar
en esta segunda igualdad como algo que se deriva directamente de esa definición. La norma traza también se puede
definir de otras maneras más generales, y la volveremos a encontrar en la próxima lección. Esto es de hecho
lo mejor que puedes hacer: esta medición es óptima asumiendo que tu objetivo es maximizar la probabilidad de una
respuesta correcta. Ese hecho a veces se llama el teorema de Helstrom-Holevo, y a veces simplemente se llama el teorema de Helstrom,
así que no puedes superar esta medición en términos de probabilidad de corrección, y es agradable porque
hay una receta simple para la propia medición y una fórmula exacta para la probabilidad de corrección en términos de la traza
La norma de traza se usa frecuentemente como forma de medir la diferencia observable entre matrices de densidad, precisamente
por esta razón, y cuando la gente habla de la distancia de traza entre estados, generalmente se refiere a
la mitad de la norma de traza de la diferencia entre las dos matrices de densidad, que aquí corresponde al caso en que p 0 y P1 son ambas 1/2, lo cual
es un caso natural a considerar. La discriminación de estados cuánticos para dos estados se resuelve de forma óptima mediante
la medición de Helstrom, para la cual tenemos una receta sencilla y una fórmula simple para la corrección
de la probabilidad. Entonces, ¿qué sucede cuando queremos discriminar entre tres o más estados? En este caso no tenemos una
fórmula general para una elección óptima de medición ni una expresión simple para la probabilidad máxima de
corrección. Sin embargo, es posible encontrar una buena aproximación de una medición óptima con la ayuda de una computadora
y, en particular, eso se puede hacer usando una técnica de optimización realmente fascinante y poderosa conocida como programación semidefinida, pero no es
algo que puedas implementar de forma factible con un lápiz y un papel, por ejemplo. Por otro lado, si alguien
te da la descripción de una medición y te afirma que esa medición es óptima para una tarea de discriminación de estados cuánticos, entonces
en realidad es muy fácil verificar o refutar esa afirmación, y eso se puede hacer usando las llamadas condiciones de Holevo-Yuen-
Kennedy-Lax. No voy a explicar qué son en este video, pero son condiciones simples y es bastante genial
que esto sea posible. Aquí hay un ejemplo que conecta con los estados tetraédricos
que vimos antes en la lección. Supongamos que nos dan uno de estos cuatro estados, seleccionado al azar con
probabilidad un cuarto para cada uno, y nuestro objetivo es determinar qué estado nos han dado. Quizás no sorprenda, pero
la mejor elección que puedes hacer para una medición en este caso es la medición tetraédrica. No siempre puedes
hacer algo así con una colección arbitraria de estados puros, pero debido a las simetrías involucradas aquí, esto sí
funciona y obtenemos una medición válida, y mediante las condiciones de Holevo-Yuen-Kennedy-Lax que mencioné
hace unos momentos, resulta bastante sencillo demostrar que esta es, en efecto, una elección óptima de
medición. En concreto, lo que ocurre aquí es que la medición siempre es correcta con probabilidad 1/2, lo cual no está
mal, ya que hay cuatro alternativas, así que la probabilidad de acertar es el doble que con una suposición aleatoria, y
resulta ser lo mejor que se puede hacer con estos estados. Ahora diré un poco más sobre la tomografía de estados cuánticos,
donde tenemos muchas copias independientes de un estado cuántico desconocido y el objetivo es encontrar una aproximación de la matriz de densidad que describe
ese estado. En realidad hay varias variantes diferentes de este problema que dependen de tus suposiciones y, en
particular, del tipo de mediciones que permitas. Por ejemplo, podríamos exigir que cada sistema se mida individualmente y
los resultados se combinen de algún modo para llegar a una descripción de la matriz de densidad, o podríamos permitir que todos
los sistemas se midan juntos como un único sistema compuesto, lo cual es mucho mejor en teoría, pero también es mucho más
exigente desde el punto de vista tecnológico. Además de las elecciones que se hacen para las mediciones, hay
también una consideración importante: cómo reconstruir una descripción de la matriz de densidad a partir de los datos que
se obtienen de las mediciones. No voy a entrar en detalles sobre esto; mi punto es simplemente sugerir
que la tomografía de estados cuánticos es realmente más un concepto paraguas con muchas variantes distintas, en lugar de ser un
procedimiento único. Ha habido mucha investigación sobre este problema, incluyendo algunos resultados
de gran avance bastante recientes que conectan el número de copias n con la precisión de la aproximación que se puede obtener, y continúa siendo un
área de investigación interesante y activa. Para terminar la lección, veamos la tomografía de estados cuánticos
para qubits y cómo podemos hacerlo. Supongamos que rho es una matriz de densidad que representa el estado de un
qubit individual, y x1 hasta xn son qubits que han sido preparados de forma independiente en el estado rho, y para
efectos de esta discusión supongamos que n es grande. Lo que podemos hacer es dividir los
sistemas en tres grupos aproximadamente iguales, y para el primer grupo realizaremos una medición con respecto a la base más-
menos. Para cada resultado correspondiente a más, anotaremos más uno, y para cada
resultado correspondiente a menos, anotaremos menos uno. Una forma más concisa de describir esta medición
es que es una medición de Pauli X, porque los estados más y menos son vectores propios de la matriz de Pauli X y los
valores propios correspondientes son más uno y menos uno, y de hecho esa también es una forma mucho más común de describirla.
En efecto, el valor esperado de la puntuación es igual a la traza de Sigma x por rho. Ahora bien, no necesariamente sabemos cuál es
ese valor esperado, pero si promediamos las puntuaciones que obtenemos a lo largo de muchos y muchos intentos, es bastante probable que obtengamos una
buena aproximación a ese valor esperado por la ley de los grandes números, y hay algunas cotas estadísticas bien conocidas que podemos aplicar
si queremos ser más cuantitativos sobre esa afirmación. Hacemos algo similar con Sigma y en el segundo tercio de los
sistemas. Lo único que cambia aquí es que usamos los estados más i y menos i, que son vectores propios de Sigma
Y, y de forma análoga para Sigma Z, cuyos vectores de la base estándar son vectores
propios. Y finalmente podemos usar la fórmula que aparece en pantalla, que nos dice cuáles deben ser los coeficientes
si rho se escribe como combinación lineal de matrices de Pauli, y sustituyendo nuestras aproximaciones para estos coeficientes
y posiblemente ajustándolos un poco para asegurarnos de obtener una matriz semidefinida positiva, obtenemos una aproximación de
rho. Por supuesto, hay detalles en los que no he entrado, como la precisión de la aproximación y el grado de
confianza que podemos esperar tener, pero esperamos que eso te dé una idea básica de una forma en que la tomografía puede realizarse en un
qubit. También es posible hacer tomografía de qubits usando la medición tetraédrica, y de hecho esto resulta
ser bastante simple y elegante, al menos en términos matemáticos. Lo que podemos hacer es realizar
solo esta única medición en todas las copias independientes de nuestro estado cuántico desconocido, y usando la
notable fórmula que se muestra aquí mismo, podemos elaborar una aproximación de nuestro estado estimando la traza de PK por
rho para cada K, según la fracción de veces que aparece el resultado de medición correspondiente. Nuevamente, esto solo funciona por
las perfectas simetrías que tenemos entre estos cuatro estados, y de hecho hay algunos problemas no resueltos realmente fascinantes relacionados con generalizaciones
de este enfoque para sistemas más grandes, y ese es un buen punto para terminar la lección. Gracias por ver esto, y
espero que te unas a mí en la próxima lección, que trata sobre purificaciones y fidelidad. Hasta luego.